[Music]
hi good evening guys my name's Eliot I
work for Samuels buy low rent hi I'm a
tonight's the property investors circle
with Jason wood hams how are you Jason
very well thank you
good tonight I'm just getting a quick
testimonial from himself he's brought
various properties with us throughout
the last 12 months and I just want to
see how he's getting on twelve months
down the line so Jake said yes when was
it you bought your first property with
Samuel leads team it's coming up for
most twelve months ago completed where
are we now into September so yeah pretty
much
mid to end of October 2016 okay where
did you reach from Samuel previously
property investment Network I've been
studying different strategies and
properties going up down the countries
where I live in sunny Sussex it's quite
a different ballgame say where did you
invest I up him also up in the Midlands
and that was a free meeting Samuel
basically helped me kickstart my passion
and my dream going forward okay so
that's brilliant did you have any
reservations before you invest in Samuel
actually for me no I see none whatsoever
you aren't you're happy to go yeah yeah
yeah I knew it worked
you know about you know blow my own
trumpet I knew the math work on new work
so with meeting Samuel at that point was
really enlightening why because it just
gave what I was working towards an
injection of base actually yeah I'm
right I'm not going mad and seeing
Samuel perform and then coming up to do
his crash course was just that
motivation you need awesome okay awesome
right so just tell me a bit about your
new expectations what you had what you
see what the customer service was like
from Samuel in his team and just go
through a bit through the process from
the early days when when you agree to
take the property until you completed
just
quickly process isn't difficult if
you're interested in investing your
money interested in prophecy you've got
to take action so you have a duel to
work yourself or you put it into the
hands of some other people like I did to
start with which was soundless group so
after the crash course signed up on
through Samuel to help me find a couple
of properties I think it was barely
three maybe four or five weeks at a
couple of properties to come up and look
at said yep like this one palace we've
also paid for a finder's fee at the time
yep here take that one and the third pal
of mine I bought long said yep it will
take that one Wow so there are three
properties and we bought one age I
bought a three up two down in all bad
three yes now for bit yeah three up two
down which is a full bed HMO in Walsall
and the big question I suppose is did it
let and how quickly did it left all
right now the quite unusual did it let
no yes it did it did let the unusual bit
and it's no word of a lie and it with my
experience year down on it doesn't
always happen this quick you could say
on average the stats to rent an HMOs
anything from like for 8 weeks my
property went live on a Friday and by
the Monday morning it was completely
there wow it doesn't happen but you did
on that first prophecy so was the HMO
conversion needed or the daughter said
you know I did have to do your
conversion did you did you use to the
conversion did you use some of power
team yes it did to start with
I know great guys and was like I wish
parish came on a little bit later
probably most second property power
whoosh what was thought the basics was
the parish was there but the actual name
of the company you know to be accurate
was set up a bit after that but the
people that did my property them also
so were powerwash but so that would be
the correct way to put it
the team yep no problems with the team
we work together
my specification with what I wanted for
my first HMO I added a few bits did I
have to probably not it was personal
choice am I happy I did yes but that was
a nice interjection for myself and my
hands-on person
hence I'm doing my properties now as
well for other people and that was
always my intent
could of just totally let it the team
yeah absolutely it have been very easy
and easy for anybody that really just
wants to be able to say okay I want to
purchase a property find it you guys can
do it and just go about your daily
business that would have been a very
easy way but that debt just wasn't made
us not what I am because I'm making a
career myself in properties as well for
now my customers a year on good that's
awesome okay so we're now talking to
down the line the tenants that you
originally put in 12 months ago yeah are
they still in place one change over a
lien all tenants but the water property
one moved on a couple of months ago room
was given it why she I'll say clean it
didn't need a clean is very lucky to
turn into a nice they're well checks out
the well sourced good reference which is
important getting a decent which company
did you use to source the tenants so use
Samuels brother Russell leads yes
awesome
now did you feel that went what was your
experiences with quick move I like them
or you know whatever way you look at it
you got to work with people that you can
trust and get on with and there are
other agencies out there that are also
you know pretty good but quick move just
dedicates in-room rents yeah average
letting agent are found from expanding
to other areas of my own back
you know it's key and I was speaking
with Russell tonight about doing some of
my properties for my customers in in
Darby and baring mind very immortal
Darby's a bit of a trek and Sam has got
customers in in Darby debt that they're
gonna get tenants out in that area as
well and you know that's key so quick
move was certainly very good for me good
good so just quickly just give me a
rundown of the picker so how much did
you pay for your pop to you morsel okay
the truth of it was hundred and five
thousand so I was hoping to get it for
the 100k why did I pay slightly over the
book I see the first property and it was
worth it just the location my house
opened a front door hospital oh wow
two minutes up the road bus stop five
minutes up the road
Town Center so awesome location yeah
very lucky with that location a little
bit of garden front and back they punkin
two more it just felt right to do it
Samuel sort like with his a sort of
found a grad limit he said you sure
you're happy to do that if you not I'll
find you another one
a nice and I sort of looked at him
smiled and I said you and me both know
you would buy this and I'm definitely
buying it because of that just very
lucky with a location so it all went
well then yeah so since you brought you
also one you've brought a few more yeah
I bought another one for Samuel in
Wolverhampton that is completed when did
that complete and it completed February
time got the work done on that got some
tenants in there I've got free tunes and
at the moment we're now looking for the
another fourth one you know but it's
going well the properties are generating
good income good and that one left okay
as well took a little bit longer that
hit them or what you call the average
which is four to six weeks as a whole as
the whole package of by low rent hi
I know you weren't using power whoosh at
the first book power whoosh now that
come on board you probably say Paris is
a name if you like that
operating but it wasn't known as pair it
wasn't there I'm sure there is
Samuels whole package that he offers on
a scale of sort of zero to ten how would
you how would you rate it now that you
can look twelve months twelve months you
know previous time alone well it'd be
very easy to say ten I think you've got
to be generous and say I'm happier
there's nothing to be unhappy about
he's what it says in the package it's
working so I'm gonna I'm gonna go for
ten for Sam awesome would you use again
I'm guessing you would well cuz he's
over educated me and I'm kind of doing
it myself
sourcing properties yes I actually got
customers that look for properties
because I'm very proactive with it you
know it's not been difficult with the
manner customers I've got to service a
need but absolutely never problem using
Samuel for sourcing or his power team if
you know it was working for me in the
area at the time so yes I would
absolutely endorse it yes
leaving I'm doing a business herself up
more than happy so I find out Samuel and
Tanya and say guys I need some
properties help what would you say to
somebody who was probably sitting on the
fence thinking oh I've got this large
amount of money you want to invest it
doing you something leads do enough what
would you say to those type of people
would you would you recommend would you
encourage it or would you well you can
leave your money in the bank
dwindling at the rate of inflation
compared to the rate of interest and if
you see us about investing in property
you've got to do something so if you're
looking to get good returning the money
even with a basic buy to let Samuel
would be ideal for that if you're not
absolutely put your buy-to-let on
steroids
there's a little bit more education and
know-how and samuel has got that in
abundance so yeah absolutely you know
you got to go to people and you got to
pay for your expert service pay do
experts go experts stuff Jason it's been
a pleasure thank you thank you supposed
to me and to you thank you coming along
yeah